[Música]
hola y bienvenidos a esta entrevista
exclusiva en esta semana europea muy
rica en acontecimientos y empezamos en
la comisión europea en parís en compañía
de michel barnier negociador jefe de la
unión europea para el break sheet desde
michel barnier fue comisario europeo de
política regional y también ex ministro
de asuntos exteriores y de agricultura
de francia entonces hoy dice que quiere
y de pesca también así es pide que
quiere dedicarse a francia y hablaremos
de ello pero en lo que respecta al break
sheet michel barnier
siente que todo terminó que bien está lo
que bien acaba desde cierto punto de
vista
de acuerdo con el mandato que me dieron
los líderes europeos los 27 jefes de
gobierno del parlamento europeo hicimos
casi todo lo que se nos pidió último hay
algo que falta en esta alianza con reino
unido en este momento porque los
británicos no lo quisieron y es la
política exterior la defensa la
cooperación con los países en vías de
desarrollo con áfrica en particular los
británicos no querían discutir sobre
esto desde el principio el año pasado en
marzo o febrero solamente no lo entendí
porque era algo bastante separado del
comercio de la seguridad interior pero
era importante y lo sigue siendo porque
tenemos una alianza con reino unido que
es un gran país que tiene una política
exterior dinámica una defensa creíble y
un puesto en el consejo de seguridad de
las naciones unidas
así que creo que hay otro capítulo que
tendrá que abrirse un poco más tarde
cuando los británicos lo quieran con
otros negociadores para esa parte por lo
demás lo que se acordó fue un acuerdo
comercial equilibrado y justo con un
acuerdo sobre la energía un acuerdo
sobre el transporte un acuerdo sobre la
pesca un acuerdo sobre la seguridad
interior eso es lo que figura en el
acuerdo que hicimos con el gran tema
olvidado en este acuerdo en estas
negociaciones es la city de londres el
7% del pib un millón de puestos de
trabajo sin equivalente sin pasaporte
europeo para la mayoría de estos
productos que dependen únicamente de la
buena voluntad de la comisión europea
con 7.500 empleados trasladados
será también objeto de otra negociación
porque boris johnson dejó a la city
fuera del acuerdo
ni la ciudad ni los servicios
financieros fueron olvidados no estaba
previsto nunca fue un tema que hiciera
parte de esta negociación a
procedimientos que hemos utilizado con
todos los grandes terceros países que
tienen servicios financieros eeuu en
primer lugar yo era comisario en el
mercado interior cuando asigné en nombre
de la comisión y bajo el control de los
estados miembros del parlamento
equivalencia para ciertos actores o
determinados sectores de los servicios
financieros de eeuu hicimos lo mismo con
japón y vamos a hacer lo mismo
unilateralmente libremente con los
británicos en determinados sectores
limitar teniendo en cuenta nuestros
intereses teniendo en cuenta algo que
interesa mucho a su audiencia que es la
estabilidad financiera de la unión
europea y de la zona euro les recuerdo
que no hay que tener memoria a corto
plazo hace muy poco en 2008 2009 fue
ayer la crisis financiera fue terrible
violenta por supuesto de una naturaleza
diferente a esta crisis que estamos
viviendo con el coronavirus pero causó
muchos daños en reinounido en irlanda en
todas partes
millones de puestos de trabajo así que
no vamos a correr riesgos con la
estabilidad financiera y esta
estabilidad está ligada a las
condiciones que necesitamos para estar
seguros supervisión regulación el
respeto de las normas europeas con los
efectos de este break sheet para evitar
la burocracia de reino unido el tráfico
entre el ser público irlanda se ha
triplicado estamos por fin
reconfigurando este comercio de facto a
través del canal de la mancha
siempre habrá grandes líneas de
conectividad entre el reino unido y el
continente tanto en el transporte de
pasajeros como en el de mercancías y la
energía pero está claro que este break
sheet que no queríamos que lamentamos
pero que llevamos a cabo porque fue una
decisión que tomó la mayoría de los
ciudadanos británicos una decisión
democrática va a hacer que un país que
es miembro de la unión europea y que
espera quedarse irlanda esté más
directamente vinculado al continente por
lo tanto en términos de energía
conectividad y conexiones de transporte
aire
que realmente se tendrán que hacer como
usted lo dijo sobre el flete
piensa que finalmente con este break si
todos pierden sigue considerando que
reinó unido- perdió más y que parte de
responsabilidad tiene boris johnson ese
primer ministro que quiso este presi
relativamente duro en el actual mal
estado de su país
no quiero comentar hoy la política
interna de reino unido más de lo que lo
hice antes reino unido- quiso o al menos
una mayoría de sus ciudadanos que
hicieron este break seal hace casi cinco
años en 2016 todavía no he entendido el
valor añadido del break shit
a decir verdad nadie ha sido capaz de
mostrarme como el break sheet tuvo un
valor añadido para reino unido y para
nosotros creo que es una situación en la
que todos pierden porque creo que fue un
debilitamiento para ambas partes no
shampoo está en un gran país y este gran
país se queda solo así que creo que
todos pierden afecta más a reino unido
evidentemente hay más procedimientos hay
más papeleo hay más limitaciones para
comerciar ya que reino unido decidió
salir de este ecosistema que
constituyamos
y que seguimos constituyendo entre
nosotros los 27 entre nosotros
armonizamos facilitamos el paso de una
frontera a otra y no hay controles
dentro de este mercado único hay
controles con el reino unido ahora así
que como reino unido- exporta mucho más
hacia la unión europea que viceversa es
entre el 50 por ciento de un lado y el 8
o 10 por ciento del otro
obviamente hay más restricciones del
lado de reino unido es una de las
consecuencias del break sheet y como
dijo theresa may break sin éxito así que
es una consecuencia automática del break
tiene la impresión de que hoy no se
corre el riesgo de que otros estados se
vean tentados a salir el bec shit los ha
disuadido
creo que todo el mundo vio a lo largo de
esta larga negociación muy larga
negociación que era complicado que había
muchas más consecuencias graves y
negativas de las que se le dijo a los
británicos cuando votaron y ahora
descubrimos esas consecuencias a veces
se dijeron mentiras durante la campaña
del referéndum el señor farage y otros
mintieron hicieron demagogia y se los
dije en la cara cuando me reuní con
ellos pero no creo que otros países
quieran hacer lo mismo porque ahora
saben lo que pasa y conocen las
consecuencias es posible para un país
salir de la unión es posible la unión
europea no es una cárcel se puede salir
de ella pero hay que asumir sus
responsabilidades y los británicos deben
asumir sus responsabilidades ahora es el
momento porque ahora el break sheet está
hecho así que en medio de una pandemia
cuando vimos a miembros de este gobierno
británico explicarnos que gracias a su
partida pudieron poner en marcha una
campaña de vacunación a gran escala con
mayor facilidad que no tuvieron que
esperar a que la comisión europea
comprara las vacunas
qué piensas
y digo que no quiero crear polémica
durante esta terrible pandemia que
afecta a millones de personas que lo
afectó en particular que me afectó pero
a muchos otros mucho más seriamente y ha
afectado a tanta gente hay muchos
muertos mucha gente enferma muchos
desempleados
francamente no quiero entrar en una
polémica con el gobierno británico lo
que puedo decir simplemente sobre esta
pandemia es que la unión europea
reaccionó y estoy muy complacido por eso
colectivamente para pedir vacunas
conjuntamente que estas vacunas son
significativamente más baratas que están
disponibles más rápidamente y que hay
más y creo que esto es algo bueno y
también creo que esta pandemia demuestra
que nos conviene estar juntos más juntos
económicamente también con un plan de
recuperación más un presupuesto
plurianual de 1800 millones de euros un
endeudamiento masivo en los mercados en
común en su opinión será suficiente con
esta tercera ola y los cambios que
estamos viendo y luego está la cuestión
del déficit público lo dejaremos pasar y
hasta dónde
con el fin de su escudo
vamos en orden por el momento no hemos
salido de esta crisis saldremos cuando
todos los ciudadanos sean vacunados de
forma equitativa y todavía no estamos
ahí aunque estemos yendo más rápido nos
enfrentamos a la situación y nos
enfrentamos juntos tanto a nivel de
organización de la respuesta en términos
de salud todavía hay que avanzar hay
lecciones que aprender de esta crisis y
luego en términos económicos
reaccionamos en primer lugar juntos para
construir el futuro presupuesto de
septiembre como saben el presupuesto
europeo se establece por siete años y no
cada año y luego por primera vez poner
en común los préstamos invertir en el
futuro invertir en la respuesta
económica en la recuperación 750 mil
millones es muy considerable es la
primera vez creo que no será la última
así que utilicemos este dinero
utilicemos lo bien utilicemos lo
rápidamente cada país ese es el objetivo
del trabajo que se está haciendo en cada
gobierno actual menciono la diplomacia
no es es el talón de aquiles de esta
unión europea vemos que tal vez nuestras
relaciones van a cambiar en qué
dirección creo que cambian
con eeuu de joe biden y además nuestras
elecciones no deberían cambiar también
cuando vemos lo que está ocurriendo con
las grandes manifestaciones las
manifestaciones pero navalny con la
rusia de vladimir putin que va en una
dirección diferente bueno yo creo que en
el mundo tal y como es y tal y como se
nos viene encima un mundo en el que
ciertos grandes países que son estados
continentes rusia como se mencionó antes
eeuu desde hace un tiempo china india
brasil en primer lugar tenemos que estar
juntos porque si cada uno está en su
casa cada uno va por su lado no contamos
no estamos en la mesa de los que
organizan o desorganizan el mundo si
queremos sentarnos en esa mesa como
europeos como franceses como alemanes
como belgas y luxemburgueses tenemos a
estar juntos como patriotas nada nos
impide seguir siendo apasionadamente
patriotas pero siendo también europeos y
para que reaccionar ante las pandemias
construir una base industrial europea
tener una política comercial común
hablar con una sola voz en relación con
los estadounidenses o los chinos y
definir juntos de forma efectiva
nuestras prioridades estratégicas qué
tipo de relación debemos tener
este gran país rusia que está cerca de
nosotros con china y asia en general y
con eeuu cuyo nuevo presidente joe biden
lo que me alegra mucho sin ser ingenuos
los estadounidenses seguirán siendo
estadounidenses y defendiendo sus
intereses en primer lugar pero al menos
el señor valdano retoma un discurso y un
lenguaje que fue el de sus predecesores
durante 60 años en lo que respecta a la
unidad de los europeos y a las alianzas
entre europa y eeuu en el marco de la
alianza atlántica en particular entonces
michel barnier en la primavera va a
publicar diario secreto del presi en la
editorial gallimard que fue lo más
secreto que ocurrió al final de esa
negociación que fue bastante
transparente a lo largo de este largo
camino de negociación quise escribir lo
que estaba viviendo lo que estaba
sintiendo lo que yo somos las lecciones
junto con las consecuencias del break
sheet y sin duda lo haré en primavera
veremos cómo y bajo qué títulos podemos
hacer público este diario es la historia
de esta negociación porque creo que es
útil conocer los detalles y también
entender esta negociación como algo más
serio que la mera relación entre la
unión europea
unido porque este break shit le planteó
preguntas a los europeos y recomiendo
que dediquemos un tiempo para aprender
porque tanto británico votaron en contra
de europa hay que aprender del
sentimiento popular que se expresó la
ira social a veces hay que escuchar hay
que entender hay que responder eso es lo
que está en juego para los europeos los
27 en los tiempos que vienen
michel barnier precisamente usted es
reconocido como un gran europeo pero ha
dicho que quiere serle útil a francia y
a su familia política la derecha los
republicanos entonces obviamente
hablando de las primarias quiere
imponerse como candidato vamos en orden
simplemente dije algo que sorprendió
quizás creó una expectativa unas
esperanzas dije que sigo siendo un
político no me convertí en un súper
tecnócrata de bruselas nunca lo he sido
soy político desde hace mucho tiempo y
mientras conserve la misma capacidad de
indignación o de entusiasmo la misma
energía lo que es el caso voy a poner
esta energía al servicio de mi país
volviendo a francia mucho más a menudo
estoy muy contento de volver a ver a los
franceses que extrañaba a mi país y de
utilizar esta energía en este país que
la necesita esto es lo que puedo decir
hoy ya veremos en todo caso no es el
momento de aventuras individuales hoy en
día cuando vemos lo que pasa en el país
con esta crisis francamente los
franceses esperan otras cosas otras
responsabilidades de un político en ese
momento de trabajar colectivamente
dicho esto a lo que respecta a su figura
quedó bien clasificada en una encuesta
del 7 de enero en el noveno puesto 27 de
opiniones favorables además el hecho de
que xavier bertrand esté por delante de
valérie pécresse en cuanto a las figuras
de la derecha le anima
volvió a la misma pregunta me alegro de
la acción que he podido llevar a cabo
durante muchos años tanto como
presidente de un departamento fui
elegido durante mucho tiempo en sagua
como miembro del gobierno fue un honor
para mí como comisario europeo hoy como
negociador que lo pude hacer y como pude
hacerlo mirando a la gente a los ojos
siendo sinceros siendo honesto evitando
las políticas inútiles creo que la
política consiste en construir el
progreso colectivo y no en alimentar las
polémicas así que quiero seguir
construyendo el progreso para mi país y
para este continente y me alegro de que
en esta encuesta que era indicativa como
todas las encuestas eso se reconozca su
paso por la escena francesa podría
asustar a un tal manuel ma con confía en
esto
francamente esa no era la pregunta el
país necesita mucha energía toda la
energía tengo relaciones cordiales con
el presidente de la república y
pertenezco a una familia política
diferente en hielo sabes siempre he
tratado de actuar a favor de un proyecto
de una determinada idea de mi país y no
en contra de ella y seguiré teniendo esa
actitud
y para el año europeo 2021 volverás en
un año en blanco en el que todo el mundo
tiene que conformarse con el gran
confinamiento y una gran crisis
económica
si por desgracia veremos cuál es el
curso de este año cuando hayamos
alcanzado un nivel de vacunación
suficiente para salir de este encierro
recurrente de estas limitaciones
recurrentes que están bloqueando al país
y creando tantas dificultades a las
pequeñas empresas a mucha gente el
gobierno está demostrando la solidaridad
y el rigor necesario
europa también lo está demostrando y
realmente creo que debemos estar
preparados para responder a estos retos
aquellos que no habíamos previsto como
esta pandemia mundial el riego más
profundo y duradero relacionado con el
cambio climático la pobreza en el mundo
el terrorismo que a menudo va de la mano
de la pobreza la forma de dominar las
finanzas mundiales es también un reto
importante que no podemos seguir
abordando cada uno por su lado y cada
quien por si mismo
por eso debemos ser patrióticos y al
mismo tiempo europeos hay ciertos temas
en los que europa tiene un verdadero
valor añadido gracias a michel barnier
por esta entrevista y gracias a ustedes
por haber visto esta emisión